it is time for hatred mail with a very
special new coronavirus related hatred
mail introduction
let's take a listen what is hatred mail
if you're allowed to shop for luxuries
like food and medicine
then we should be allowed to clap our
hands together in a mega church
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom all right love that i
actually have two new um hatred or
coronavirus themed intros
we'll play the next one next week i
think you'll like it let's get right
into it
this week's edition of hatred mail it
goes after you
it goes after our audience and our
followers and our subscribers take a
listen
i want free sh [ __ ] losers in this
channel
get a real job that offers real
insurance
gtfo of your lazy asses
btw trump is still your president
lmao david parkman is a user
and y'all fall for it sheep parkman
failed utterly
you are less than nothing and also
subscribers seriously 800k
who are these morons count me out listen
go after me i can take it i'm a big boy
don't go after our subscribers and by
the way if you're going to
state the correct number of subscribers
we are not at 800 000 subscribers in
fact at last check
we are almost at hundred and twenty six
thousand subscribers on youtube
we're at thirty three thousand on twitch
we're at a hundred and twenty thousand
on facebook we have a combined two
hundred thousand followers on twitter so
yes
the numbers are growing and it's thanks
to you and i'm so appreciative of that
and it seems the hatreds are getting
very very triggered you know for years
i've been dealing with
hate messages that say david i'm so glad
your show is circling the drain david
i'm so
glad you will soon be gone and your
views are being reduced to zero
and fortunately and this is not because
of me it's because of you
things have gone in the opposite
direction and we're really so grateful
and we're gonna do sort of like a state
of the show update coming up at some
point soon
where i'm going to talk you through all
of the different
things that have been going on with the
show and some of them are very very
exciting
a lot to quote our president a lot of
them are very exciting
in the meantime fight patriotism by
using the code hatred 40
when you get a membership on my website
the coupon code h-a-t-r-i-o-t-40
will save you 40 off of any membership
at joinpakman.com